[Musique]
bonjour mon propos est de vous parler de
l'élément invisible au cinéma d'un
scénario bien particulier on l'entend
plus ou moins qu'on écoute parfois et
qui dans tous les cas un vrai impact
émotionnel à savoir la musique de film
bonjour mon propos est de vous parler de
l'élément invisible au cinéma d'un
scénario bien particulier que l'on
entend parfois l'on m'écoute peut-être
et qui dans tous les cas un vrai impact
émotionnel savoir les spéciales comme
vous l'avez constaté
j'ai répété deux fois la même phrase et
pourtant dans chacune d'elles
l'atmosphère était différente
la première j'ai composé une petite
musique plutôt des comédies où on peut
se dire que cette intervention à haut
risque d'être plutôt légère avec des
l'humour la deuxième par contre c'est
une musique un peu plus lourde un peu
plus romantique où l'atmosphère est
différente et où on s'attend pas
forcément à voir cette légèreté qui
avait dans la première musique
eh bien voyez-vous c'est comme ça
qu'elle fonctionne la musique de film
elle nous manipule nous embobine
l'oreille elle nous emmène à l'autre
bout du monde à nous terrorise nous fait
rire et nous fait peur elle vous fait
pleurer
elle anticipe l'action ou bien
l'expliquent si dès l'invention du
cinématographe les musique accompagne
les films muets pour entre autres
couvrez le bruit du projecteur est aussi
appréhender le silence des images les
musiciens eux comprennent très vite
qu'elle a un impact direct sur les
spectateurs alors ses musiciens mais il
commence à improviser à écrire des
musiques coller aux images et qui
pouvait traduire les divers émotion que
le spectateur était censé traversée il y
avait des musiques d'amour il y avait
des musiques de gala il y avait des
musiques romantiques et des musiques de
tristesse
il y avait tout ça et petit à petit
c'est comme ça que le métier de musique
de file de compositeur de musique de
film est née à partir du parlant
notamment c'est à dire à partir de 1927
ce métier va devenir vraiment un métier
toutefois il s'agit pas d'être un bon
musicien et même un bon compositeur pour
pouvoir faire de la musique de film il
faut aussi comprendre vinage savoir la
déchiffrer savoir si elle appelant à une
deuxième d'une troisième dimension de
lui donner du relief de l'épaisseur et
surtout et avant tout il faut bien
écouter le réalisateur alors on va
prendre un exemple je vais vous montrer
deux fois le même générique dont j'ai
composé la musique d'un film encore en
devenir pour être d'écrire mon travail
il s'agit donc de mettre en musique une
histoire d'amour le film s'appelle
ghosting c'est donc une histoire d'amour
qui finira mal en fait
et dans le personnage principal ne se
remet pas alors je vous montre les
images telles qu'elles m'ont été donnés
à savoir sans bruit et je sais que par
rapport au scénario qui aura pas de
bruit de ville ou en tout cas elles
seront vraiment suffisamment ténu pour
que la musique prenne toute la place
bout on voit donc un jeune homme qui
marche dans la rue sont pas été assez
tranquille il semble savoir où aller ils
écoutent de la musique en tout cas là
des écouteurs dans les oreilles est bon
se passe pas grand chose
alors que faire dans un générique comme
ça je sais bien que c'est une histoire
d'amour qui va finir mal en attendant le
générique l'huile est plutôt neutre donc
est ce que je vais faire une musique
légère
après tout la fille l'a pas rencontré il
n'a pas encore rencontré et il sait pas
encore qu'il va rencontrer une fille qui
va lui briser le coeur et le spectateur
non plus même s'il se doute que c'est
une histoire d'amour on sait pas encore
quand ça commence
bon alors voici le premier générique
[Musique]
en
voici donc ce premier essai de
génériques
mon argument pour le réalisateur c'était
que cette action se situe dans le
présent c'est pas un flash back
elle met en lumière une certaine
nonchalance c'est l'été tout va bien il
n'y a pas de virus dans l'air et puis la
musique accompagne aussi parfois les pas
du personnage et il me dit non non non
non non ça va pas du tout du tout du
tout c'est pas ça que je veux c'est pas
ça que je veux je veux qu'on sente dès
le départ qu'il ya un drame
alors qu'est ce que tu veux dire par un
drame mais un drame c'est à dire qu'il
veut une musique qui soit plutôt
romantique et ouvriers de la solitude où
l'on sente la solitude du personnage
bon eh ben ça veut dire que je vais
mettre des cordes des gens tapis de
cordes pour tapisser l'ambiance
et puis un instrument de musique y est
bien pour la solitude aussi c'est le
piano 20 pianos qui joue tout le temps
mais un piano qui égrène des notes de ci
de là ça c'est assez pratique et surtout
je dois faire abstraction du fait que le
personnage marche et de tenir compte des
pas qu'il fait je dois plutôt anticiper
l'histoire la musique doit anticiper
tout ce qui va se passer après le
générique on va vraiment comprendre
qu'en fait le personnage veut vivre
quelque chose de douloureux
alors voici maintenant la musique
originale
[Musique]
babin
voilà c'est donc la musique qui sera
retenu parmi sept autres thèmes que je
lui avais proposé et qui ont donné lieu
à des grosses discussions autour ce qui
est complètement normal dans le métier
maintenant prenons un autre exemple vous
prenez un espace dans la rue un homme et
une femme se regarde son face à face
qu'est ce qui va se passer pour lui si
vous si vous ne voulez absolument pas
influencer votre spectateurs ne mettez
pas de musique
mettez pas de musique du tout comme ça
il pourra se demander tout et son
contraire selon le thème du film selon
le titre du film selon tout un tas de
critères et même les bruitages il faudra
faire attention en ce moment là si vous
ne voulez vraiment pas influencer votre
spectateurs
sinon si vous mettez musique romantique
on va penser qu'ils vont tomber amoureux
si vous mettez une musique de suspense
de musique de peur pas très agréable à
écouter qui nous met dans un stress à ce
moment là c'est évident qu'on va pouvoir
penser qu'il va leur arriver un drame ou
bien que l'un des deux est un état
meurtrier
si vous mettez une musique de comédies
légères bon ben vous avez déjà
l'explication de ce que ça va donner
c'est aussi c'est aussi comme ça qu'on
sait si on va aimer un film vous n'avez
pas remarqué quand vous regardez le
générique d'un film c'est assez souvent
qu'on peut se dire
donc je pense qu'on peut regarder ce
film là ou bien non pas pour aujourd'hui
ou bien je suis pas d'humeur ou bien au
contraire à tiens voilà un barrage d'un
film qui commence bien j'ai envie de
voir ce genre de film parce que la
musique va nous complètement nous
immerger de dans les images et la
musique c'est évident c'est une osmose
entre les deux mais sur des images
neutre c'est vraiment la musique qui
peut vous donner l'envié ou pas de
continuer à regarder ce film peut
dissocier du régime
maintenant quelle est la couleur
lustrale qu'on va donner une musique
c'est à dire les arrangements bien
l'orchestration qu'on va mettre avec une
musique c'est important parce que
toute l'ambiance toute la couleur dont
je parle et on va complètement nous
influencer aussi est-ce que vous pouvez
l'imaginer dingue vador dans la guerre
des étoiles dont le thème serait jouée
par une flûte à bec et une jolie petite
harpe dessus qui accompagne vous voyez
ça paraît juste ridicule pour un thème
comme dark vador il faut des cuivres
il faut des cuivres bien sonore il faut
des bases s'il faut des contrebasses il
faut des violences elles il faut
vraiment une
toute cette lourdeur vraiment martial
qu'implique le personnage de dark vador
et maintenant les musiques de peur elles
sont intéressantes à faire celle là et
c'est pas très facile parce que il faut
que le spectateur ne soit jamais rassuré
sur ce qui va voir sa part être une
vérité comme ça mais en fait il faut que
la musique ne soit pas rassurante il n'y
a pas mal des techniques
là j'ai envie de vous parler du
générique d'alien ce film absolument
terrorisant de ridley scott dont 10
rigole smith a fait la musique grâce à
des techniques orchestrale dit rigole
smith va faire jouer ses instruments de
telle façon qu'on ait l'impression
d'entendre comme des grognements
d'insectes et ça le corps humain
l'écroulement d'insectes vos promet il
aime pas du tout donc est déjà un petit
comme un petit stress qui se met parce
que de toute façon le corps ne va pas
aimer
après ça il peut mettre des instruments
il peut demander à ces instruments par
exemple de souffler dans l'instrument
mais sans émettre de son ouvrage juste
le vent qui passe
ça donne un climat vraiment particulier
qu'on n'a pas l'habitude d'entendre
maintenant on va faire des musiques très
tonale mais plutôt des musiques qu'on
appelle un tonale c'est à dire où on
n'aura pas les repères qu'on peut avoir
d'habitude quand on écoute une musique
quand on écoute la radio et notamment on
peut aller puiser dans ce qu'on appelle
des musiques contemporaines
certaines musiques contemporaines en
tout cas et puis il va aussi faire le
jeu du silence
tous les orateurs savent qu'il n'ya rien
de tel qu'un silence pour
non c'est une salle alors tout d'un coup
on voit un personnage qui marche dans un
couloir et on va mettre un silence et la
l'oreille va attendre attendre attendre
de savoir ce qui va se passer pour
pouvoir se rassurer parce qu'on a ça le
corps humain on a toujours envie d'être
assuré alors nous avec la musique dans
tout faire sauf nous rassurer donc on
peut mettre un silence avec ou une
résolution qui soit très forte comme un
gros coup qui peut faire sursauter le
spectateur ou bien au contraire c'est
tapis de cordes dont je vous parlais un
tapis de cordes dans le fond à fond
sonore mais un peu vaseux lourd qu'on
n'entend pas très très bien mais qui est
là quand même
et qui va faire que déjà on va pas se
sentir à l'aise parce qu'on sait pas ce
tapis sonore ce qui a deux sus un peu
comme si on marchait sur un sol mouvant
sur lequel on n'a pas de prise
et puis après on va mettre ou des
sonorités ou des mélodies qui vont être
différentes et qui vont apporter un
coude aiguë qui sera pas forcément celui
qu'on attendait pour faire durer
éventuellement le suspense une fois qui
a revolution du suspense on peut faire
une musique plus forte est peut-être
plus évidente mais en tout cas toutes
les musiques de suspense si vous placez
par hitchcock entre autres pour les
écouter elles sont tout comme ça on sait
pas où on va on sait pas comment on y va
on ne sait pas comment ça va finir
et c'est évident que l'oreille elle alla
temps les résolutions de la musique même
si on n'en est pas conscient mais ça ça
n'a aucune importance
ça fait partie de la magie de la musique
de film alors pour finir je voudrais
vraiment vous encourager à écouter et
pour ça je vous donne un petit truc ce
qui est assez pratique c'est que quand
vous regardez un film des temps en temps
vous pouvez fermer les yeux une deux
trois secondes à davantage c'est pas la
peine parce que dès qu'on ferme les yeux
en fait c'est l'oreille qui prend le
relais et c'est un bon moyen pour
vraiment écouter ce qui se passe non
seulement la musique mais la bande son
aussi c'est à dire tous les bruitages
tous les bruits qui a tout
je vous parlais des musiques de la peur
et dieu sait si les bruitages sont
importants des silences sont importants
mais les bruitages qui vont venir
s'ajouter petit à petit dessus parfois
c'est juste suffisant pour vraiment
faire peur aux spectateurs ça fait
partie de la musique ses bruitages et de
vous pouvoir vous imprégner de cette
bande son comme une qualité à part qui
est fait pour le film et je vous promets
que je vous promets vous allez vivre
vraiment des grands moments quand vous
pourrez vraiment ouvriers non seulement
les yeux mais aussi les oreilles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]